hallo mein name ist flugraum über die
hälfte der leute definitives video hier
gerade anschauen sind noch kein
abonnenten von einem kanal von geklickt
jan unter dem video auf abonnieren und
aktiviert die glocke um keine videos in
zukunft mehr zu verpassen allerdings
kümmern wir uns heute wieder um ein paar
rätsel
zum beispiel hier um einen hasen der das
war falsch der hase muss zur karotte
kommen ich kann springen drücken dann
springe ich aber es klappt nicht
ich habe auch nur noch drei leben ich
versuche jetzt einfach mal die karotte
anzuklicken nicht dass das geht auch
nicht den hass anzuklicken das geht auch
nicht oben ist zeit ist seine zeit
ich dachte auch nicht ich muss doch ging
wie hey
auch keine tipps ein paar sekunden
später ich brauchte es tipp 1 wörter
können als brett verwendet werden auf
dem das häschen springen kann also wir
wörter online
online
nein das ist so was kommen matthäus ist
jetzt matthäus bitte gib ein
fünfstelliges zahlen passwort ein ok
unternehmen steht error einen
fünfstelligen zahlen passwort ist der
fünfte buchstabe im alphabet er ist er
das macht jetzt schon keinen sinn mehr
falsch ich dachte halt drei wegen her
und ehre es eine 7 und 0 1 0
der spiegel reflektiert eine korrekte
antwort 70 77
[Musik]
ich war so nah dran ich schaffe das
spiel echt nur mit tipps machen wir
allerdings weiter mit diesem rätsel hier
hilft dem häschen zu gewinnen staat also
ich muss ich muss ich muss ganz oft
draufdrücken glaube ich habe das ding
ist trotzdem schneller das kag fährt
kann ich das fertige lasst die vierte
glühbirne aufleuchten ich kann hier die
glühbirne nicht anklicken ich kann hier
nichts einer staatlichen leuchten
ich muss im passenden moment stoff
drücken ein physiker der seinesgleichen
sucht
und wahrscheinlich einer müllhalde
finden bitte notieren die ja eine
zweistellige nummer gemäß dem bild gemäß
des bildes muss erst mal heißen weil der
dativ dem genitiv halt's maul
was soll ich mir jetzt hier notieren ich
könnte alle seiten einfach mal zusammen
zählen das sind in der horizontalen auf
jeden fall 30 plus die zehn links am
rand sind 40 plus die vier dort sind 44
da fehlt nämlich noch 44 das sind 52 56
müsste eigentlich richtig sein alles
klar
das war ich gerade in der mathe klausur
ab heute aufdrücken gedrückt halten
nicht ich meine ich kann jetzt alle
zweistelligen zahlen durchgehen aber es
wäre kein bock mehr ich kann mir ich hab
doch den opfern gerechnet
mein gott ich bin das was ist denn bei
mir rausgekommen 56 glaube ich dass
dieser wahnsinn
ich wusste wie es funktioniert
allerdings hat es am ende bescheuerten
mathekenntnisse dann gelegen dass es
gescheitert ist er stelle ein rechteck
mit ungleichen angrenzenden seiten mit
ungleichen angrenzenden seiten nicht
verstehen ich mal die aufgabenstellung
[Musik]
ratet mal was
ich war gerade dabei mir ja das war
gewollt
wolf
war ja auch gewollt eine einfache frage
führe die folgende gleichung durch drei
plus 5 gleich drei ich habe gold hände
das was ich anfasse
das
das funktioniert tippe auf einen
schmetterling über den texten also das
ist ja auch relativ easy beim tippen
schmitter linken hilft das saft sediment
am boden zu trinken was ist ein saft
sediment ist frage nummer eins sagen
okay wir können sie nicht ins gesicht
boxen
wir nehmen den saft kann mir auch nichts
machen hier können wir nichts machen da
kriegt nichts machen kann auch nichts
verschieben sagt auch schon öffnet das
man dann irgendwie ach guck mal hier was
ist denn das hier überhaupt und was
essen das hier überhaupt
aber jetzt mal real taxi wird irgendein
saft sediment am boden trinken oder ist
das französischen heiße dimon
jeder ansatzweise intelligente mensch
wirklich garaus machen aber ich kann ja
nichts machen ich kann dir nichts
verschieben
allerdings wohl drauf klicken kann ich
irgendwas gleichzeitig drücken jetzt
geht auch nicht den schnuller ich glaube
ich glaub ich brauchen typical unsere
den unteren teil zu ihren kunden
[Musik]
das ging gerade noch nicht
das ging
aber gut freunde von solchen kleinen
rückschlägen lassen wir uns natürlich
nicht beirren setzte die formen in den
richtigen rahmen zack zack und so blöd
[Applaus]
[Musik]
finde die unterschiede ist unsere
aufgabe in diesem nächsten rätsel hier
ich kann hier nicht wo soll ich denn der
unterschied finden
ich klicke einfach wieder überlegen ich
denke einfach wieder gebannt auf
irgendwas werden wir schon finden
da gibt es noch mehr
gibt es noch mehr
gar nichts finde
wenn ich hier gar nichts finde
man wollte mich nach von rechts nach
links anja unerwartet nicht eigentlich
nicht ich bin ja schon relativ schlau
wie viele löcher hat diese hose haha das
kenne ich auf jeden fall emmely hat oben
ein loch natürlich klar dass die beiden
taschen 23 unten die beiden wohl beide
rauskommen 34
45 und 56 die beiden löcher natürlich
sechs löcher
doch hinaus auch taschen beachte dass es
zwei löcher auf der vorderseite und zwei
löcher auf der iss
[Musik]
wenn wir frage ich mich echt wie ich
mein abi und meinen bachelor geschafft
habe ihn wie viele stücke kann eine
wassermelone mit zehn schnitten
höchstens geschnitten werden und kann
ich ja strandnähe mit zehn schnitten
höchstens geschnitten werden schon
einmal durch hast du zwei die beiden
durch das sind 4 8 16 32 64 128 256 512
und dann haben wir eine melone mit 1024
stück
[Musik]
[Applaus]
super job als faul wie kann man dieses
level abschließen wir haben ja einen
mauszeiger und einem aus wir haben ja
gar nicht apple ja abschließen und wir
nehmen das dings
komm gib ihm vergessen nicht die maus zu
benutzen bewegen und mit der rechten
maustaste auch nein das ist jetzt nicht
wahr
hier drauf und dann ich frage mich
wirklich ob ich so blöd bin dass ich da
nicht selbst drauf komme oder ob die
rätsel einfach extrem blöd sind aber ich
würde sagen meine lieben freunde wir
kommen jetzt auch schon zum letzten
rätsel für das heutige video bilder die
kleinste mögliche zahl okay natürlich
wird man da denken 56 8 555 auch falsch
kann man hier die drei gehen das geht
nicht
es gibt auch nicht die kleinstmögliche
zahl
das ist die 5 das ist die 5 die fünf ist
die kleinstmögliche zu halten ich kann
das hochschieben diana nicht
kommt noch ein tipp erhebe das erste
zeichen und gibt 99 1 - 9
ich schwöre ich fahre zu diesen app
entwicklern nach hause und an der stelle
wird das video ist allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
der heutige teil brainard mit luca
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da wenn ihr
auch weiterhin wollt dass sich in diesem
spiel auf meinem kanal verzweifelt und
jetzt befinden wir uns auch schon im
auto hier oben findet ihr ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte man
kann kostenlos abonniert und verpasst
keine videos mehr und hier ist ein video
verlinkt das soeben auf einem zwei kanal
online gegangen ist und zwar habe ich
darin auf das neue iphone 12 pro
reagiert also schaut euch auf jeden fall
mal an es wird
ja schaut einfach selbst